-You look stunning.
Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-Rina, we were your first show
where you made your music debut.
-Yes.
-That was your first
late-night show.
Which -- Yeah, we all know you.
We love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But now this is your first
late-night talk-show interview.
-Crazy.
-I'm also your first.
-Crazy! I love it!
-We're in the history books.
I'm honored. I'm honored
to be in the history books.
This is also your first film.
-Yes.
-Which I almost can't believe
that's real that I'm saying that
because you're phenomenal
in this film.
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
I can't believe it, either.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're -- I mean,
it's a giant --
Do you get nervous
when you're doing a film
as opposed to performing live
as a -- as a musician?
-Oh, I -- It is a completely
different experience.
-Different animal.
-I don't really get nervous
before shows.
-You don't?
-No.
I get very excited,
but it's not nerves.
-Well, how about this?
Look at this show right here.
This is Tokyo Garden Theater.
Look at how many people.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're not --
You don't get nervous for that?
-Past, like, 3,000 people,
I feel like -- the human eye,
you can't really understand
what's going on.
You know what I mean.
Do you know what I mean?
-That's very interesting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, after a certain amount,
you're like, "Who cares?
3,000 -- 3 million."
-No, it's -- You --
-No, in a good way.
-No, I still
can't understand it.
-You can't see further
than that?
-Yes.
-When I did stand-up --
This is back in the day and
people were allowed to smoke
in stand-up -- in comedy clubs.
And so it was
all smoke and lights.
So all you saw were maybe...
-Two people.
-...a row, two people, yeah.
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Oh, I can do this."
-Right. Yeah.
-Then they banned smoking,
and all of a sudden, like,
"There's all these people here?"
Like -- This is like --
"Wow. I don't want to do this.
This is crazy."
-Bring in the haze.
-Yeah. "I want the haze."
You want that, yeah.
But this is --
this is a giant thing.
You're opposite Keanu Reeves.
-Yeah.
-When you're in and you're --
Dude, you carry the film
with Keanu, right?
I mean, you're amazing in it.
Do you get -- Was he --
What was he like
when you get there?
Are you like, "Oh, I just don't
want to flub my lines.
I want to do..."
-Yeah, I mean --
So, we had, like,
five weeks of training
before the five weeks
of shooting,
which is all at nighttime,
by the way.
So it's -- Yeah.
Oh, I mean, if you see any of
the action scenes in the movies,
they're usually shot
1:00 a.m. to 5:00 a.m.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
-So, what's your
sleep schedule like?
-It's 8:00 a.m. to 1:00 p.m.
-Wow. So you're a vampire.
-Yeah. Honestly.
We'd be wearing sunglasses
on the way home
so we wouldn't get any sunlight.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
And all of our skin
went a bit gray.
-It did?
-It's not --
Like, you know,
you're climatized to it.
You try and, you know,
adjust your sleep schedule.
But you need vitamin D.
Like, everyone goes a bit crazy.
-But you look so --
Everyone looks so cool.
It's so stylized,
and the movie is awesome.
I mean, yeah,
you know the "John Wick" --
If you haven't seen it.
But it has everything.
The lighting,
the direction is so good.
-Oh, it's amazing. Yeah.
-How did the director know
that you were right
for this part?
-Oh, my -- So, it's honestly
like a Hollywood miracle,
like, fairy-tale story.
-I love these stories.
-So, basically,
I had just finished writing
my second album, not fully,
but the bulk of it.
And I was -- I was having
a creative block before that.
So it was like kind of --
It was amazing that I met --
I managed to write most of it
in two months.
And never in my schedule have
I ever had a couple months free.
But because I had finished
that block of work,
there was a couple month free
after that.
And then I just randomly get
a call from Chad Stahelski.
He wants to speak with me.
I'm like, "Why the [bleep]
does he want to speak to me?"
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Why does director of "John
Wick" want to speak with me for?
-Yeah.
-Right?
-I would think, "Great."
I would take the call.
-I took the call.
-Yeah.
-You go, "What's your problem?"
-And then he was like --
Yeah. Yeah.
"What do you want?
What do you want?"
So, I spoke with him,
and he was like,
"So, I've been trying
to cast this role."
And he described the character.
And, "What are you doing
for the next three months?"
-That -- Just like that?
-Just like that.
-But did he know that you --
you can fight and --
and kick and run around and flip
and roll and shoot arrows?
-He didn't, and I didn't.
-Okay, perfect.
Alright. Good.
-So...
But you know what?
There was a conspiracy.
-Uh-huh.
-It was my conspiracy.
Because I'd -- So, I co-direct
some of my videos,
and I write some of my videos,
as well.
So, I wrote into my videos
the fact that I'll be, like,
acting as a character,
so there's a video called "XS"
where I'm acting like a robot
and I'm breaking down.
-Yeah.
-And there's a -- there's
a video called "Bad Friend"
where I'm looking like
a Japanese salary man
and doing a fight scene.
-Yeah.
-Honestly, I was thinking,
"You know what?
If I've got this budget
to do a music video,
I'm going to also make it
my acting portfolio."
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm gonna get..."
Smart. So smart.
-And it worked!
Because he said, "I've been
watching your videos.
Keanu and I watched
your 'Bad Friend' video
and 'XS' video
and was so impressed because
clearly you do stunts."
Because I did fighting
in "Bad Friend."
-Yeah.
-"And clearly you can act
in 'XS.'"
-Yeah.
And you're -- you're funny in
some of your videos, as well.
-Thank you.
-Which that'll be the next movie
you do.
You'll do a comedy.
-Oh, that would be sick.
It's hard, though.
Comedy's hard.
-Nah.
-"Eh."
[ Laughter ]
-You crush it so awesomely
in this.
You're coming out -- Again,
bow and arrow, bow and arrow,
flipping, rolling,
kicking, everything,
then use the arrow.
-Yeah.
-Stabbing people with
your arrow -- your bow.
-Yep, doing splits.
-How much training goes
into all this stuff?
'Cause it's you, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was five weeks of training.
-Yeah.
-Which is not enough.
-No.
-And then the first week,
they were like,
"Oh, we're just
going to do some drills
just to get you warmed up."
-Yeah.
-And I --
I think it was honestly
the first day of training.
I did a move that we --
You just dodge underneath.
Like, you're in a squat position
and you just dodge like this.
-Yeah, that's it.
-And then like this.
-Yeah, I would throw my back out
and be out...
-Okay. Listen.
So, I threw my back out.
[ Laughter ]
-Guy's like, "Who cast her?"
-First day.
-Yeah. First day?
-Yeah, first day.
-So you don't tell anybody,
right?
-How embarr--
No, I didn't tell anyone.
-Of course not.
-So, I pinched I nerve.
So, I don't know if anyone
has pinched a nerve before.
Well, it does --
-It's terrible.
-It grabs the muscles
around your nerve,
and it shrinks it.
So, I was trying to hide it.
But after a couple of days, my
spine started going like this.
So I was walking like this.
-And you're like --
-I was just --
And then I was like, "No, no.
It's absolutely fine.
I'm not in pain."
-Yeah, everybody's like --
They're like,
"Rina, why are you doing this?"
-Your spine
is literally like this.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
And then they were like,
"You need to go get some help."
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-And then, by the end of it,
did you get so into it?
You're like, "Oh.
This is my second calling.
Now I want to get into like..."
-I would love to do more.
-You would?
-I would love to do -- It's the
hardest thing I've ever done,
but I would love to do more.
-You couldn't have
crushed it harder, bud.
-Thank you.
-Couldn't have
crushed it harder.
-Thank you.
-Well, well, well done.
-How do we set up what
the movie's about without
spoiling "John Wick: Chapter 4"?
-This is --
This is the weird thing about
promoting a movie
versus promoting music.
-Yeah, because
you can talk about the music.
-Because you can talk
about the music.
You can't talk about a movie.
-Yeah.
-So, of course, I'm like --
Am I spoiling?
Okay, but -- my character --
-[ Imitates buzzer ]
-Right!
-No, you can't say that.
-No, that's --
-Can't say that.
-Lionsgate...I'm gone.
-Let's try it a different way.
-Yeah.
-Well, I think we're allowed
to say what John is doing.
John is trying to --
-John's killing more people.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-In the first ten seconds.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In the first ten seconds.
There's -- There's nunchucks.
There's throwing stars.
-A lot of that.
-There's everything
you would never thought.
You go, "Oh, my God."
There's horses.
-Yeah.
-In the first ten --
Horseback.
-All from one dead dog.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-All for one --
Don't mess with someone's dog.
-That's true.
-Don't mess with someone's pet.
-I get it. I've got a dog.
-Yeah.
-I totally get it.
-Don't mess with that.
Yeah, that's -- Yeah, exactly.
That's the best way
to set it up.
-Yeah.
-Don't mess with someone's dog.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Rina Sawayama
in "John Wick: Chapter 4."
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-If they find you here,
the Table will kill my father.
Me. Everyone.
Because you broke the rules.
You shouldn't have come.
♪♪
You armed?
-Yeah! Are you kidding me?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rina Sawayama!
"John Wick: Chapter 4" is in
theaters and IMAX March 24th.
We'll be right back with
stand-up from Nore Davis.
Stick around, everybody.